هي تداعيات الانسانيه للاشتباكات الجاريه
في السودان حذر فرحان حق نائب المتحدث
باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده حذر من
ان استمرار الصراع في السودان سيؤدي الى
زياده عدد من يعانون انعدام الامن الغذائي
وان عدد هؤلاء قد يصل الى 19 مليون شخص
خلال الاشهر المقبله واشار حقل الحاجه
لتوفير نحو نصف مليار دولار لدعم احتياجات
طالبيه اللجوء في الدول المجاوره للسودان
يتوقع برنامج الاغذيه العالمي ارتفاع عدد
الذين يعانون من انعدام امن غذائي في
السودان ما بين مليوني شخص ومليونين ونصف
مما سيرفع العدد الى 19 مليون شخص اذا
استمر الصراع خلال الاشهر السته المقبله
وكاله اللاجئين اعلنت ان هناك حاجه الى
445 مليون دولار لدعم تدفق نحو 860 الف
لاجئ وعائد من السودان في خمس دول متضرره
من الوضع